[Music]
hi mystery recapped here today i am
going to explain a south korean mystery
thriller film called the silenced
spoilers ahead watch out and take care
the premise of the movie is set in 1938
when korea is under japanese rule in
seoul a woman is driving her teenage
stepdaughter shizuko to an all-girls
sanatorium school it is a place where
sickly girls are brought to improve
their health by regulating their diet
and providing them with proper medicine
shizuko doesn't want to stay away from
her family but her stepmother is adamant
about keeping her in the sanatorium she
plans to go on a trip to tokyo to join
her husband after dropping her off the
girls of the school excitedly look
outside the window intrigued by the new
member about to be added to their school
the principal welcomes shizuko and
promises to make her healthy in no time
then the counselor of the school goes
through her luggage and throws away
everything but her clothes shizuko wants
to keep a notebook with her but the
counselor slaps her in the face for
disobedience kazuei is one of the
members of the sanatorium she is kind
and gentle unlike most of the girls she
welcomes shizuko and tells her that the
counselor was harsh on her just because
it is her first day with time she is
sure to fit in with everyone else
shizuko is taken to the embroidery class
to be introduced to the rest of the
members of the school when they find out
that her name is shizuko they look at
each other in confusion a girl named
kihira helps her catch up with the class
and makes friends with her in the
process before going to bed the girls
are given a strange medicine that is
supposed to improve their health shizuko
doesn't think much of it and eats it
like the rest at midnight the unsaid
leader of the girls yuka wakes shizuko
and brings her to another room she
bullies her and hits her with pebbles
suddenly shizuko coughs blood and falls
to the floor casuay arrives and orders
the girls to get out she and yuka used
to be friends but they have turned into
rivals recently the following morning
shizuko is summoned to the principal's
office the principal gives her a strange
tea and tells her about a competition
every year they select two physically
outstanding students to send them to
tokyo for further studies in a
prestigious school every girl is
competing to win the grand prize and the
principal wants shizuka to do the same
following that shizuko is injected with
a dose of the medicine that the
counselor says will help eliminate her
illness while returning to the room
kihira approaches her and reveals that
someone of her name used to live with
them not long ago it turns out that yuka
kazuei and the older shizuka were best
friends but one day shizuko disappeared
mysteriously without informing anyone
later casaway takes shiziko to an
underground hidden storeroom she had
found a notebook in the room some time
ago and wants shiziko to have it since
hers was taken away by the counselor the
two befriend each other while talking
about their past in school the level of
physical fitness is measured by how long
the girls can jump in their next
physical test yuka and casaway score the
highest shizuko however cannot even make
the jump later during lunch the
principal asks the girls to take their
medicine every day and on time she
emphasizes that the medicine is
prescribed to them according to their
physical condition and will help them
get better shizuko quietly asks kahira
what the old shizuka was like all of a
sudden kahira attacks her and tries to
choke her to death cazaway saves shiziko
but kihira starts to struggle on her own
her bones crackle and a white foamy
substance comes out of her mouth a while
later kihira is back to normal and
doesn't remember losing her temper
shizuko apologizes to her nonetheless
the next day casaway and shizuko sneak
out of the school and walk through the
forest after walking for a while they
reach a river shiziko is overjoyed as
she has never seen a river in her life
in the following physical test shizuko
manages to jump longer than most of the
girls and lands in the third position
after causeway and yuka her health
starts to improve and she believes that
it is because she finally has a friend
she can rely on seeing shizuka and
causeway spending time together yuka
gets jealous she puts a dead bird in
shiziko's closet and tells her that she
will always be pathetic however now that
shizuko is healthy she doesn't back down
she puts the dead bird on yuka's plate
during breakfast to retaliate one day
shizuko discovers a notebook under
cassaway's mattress and decides to check
it inside she finds a torn picture of
causaway then she notices a necklace on
the floor but before she can pick it up
a hand emerges from under the bed and
takes it away on checking shizuko finds
no one under the bed seconds later a
gruesome looking girl appears on the
other side of the room shizuko runs
outside in fear and bumps into the
counselor when she checks under the bed
again she is surprised to see no one
then a girl named iguchi mysteriously
disappears the principal announces that
her mother came in last night and took
her home shizuko doubts the story
because the girl under the bed looked
exactly like iguchi she tries telling
kazawe about the matter but is dismissed
following that kihira asks her if she
really saw iguchi when shizuko confirms
she asks her to look under the stairs to
her horror another girl in the same
condition as iguchi lies inside when
shizuko retreats in fear she bumps into
kahira who is now choking herself when
asked what is wrong she drops to the
floor and struggles to get up her bones
crackle and her body folds in half
shizuko runs to call the counselor but
when they return both kihira and the
other girl are absent shizuko is sent to
the principal's office who declares that
she is hallucinating and needs a greater
dosage of medicine she also says that
kihira has transferred to another school
as of that morning shizuko is now sure
that something about the school is off
later she and casaway are together on
the playground talking about different
things shiziko knows that casaway has
been nice to her because she reminds her
of the previous shizuko who lived with
them she doesn't mind being a substitute
but she doesn't like the fact that
casaway doesn't care about her if it
weren't for the older shiziko casaway
keeps quiet confirming that she in fact
takes care of shizuko only because of
her old friend angered shizuko jumps
like they do on a physical exam and
crosses the entire runway both of them
are just as shocked as the other they go
to the bathroom where shiziko says that
she feels weird and asks for her help
this reminds casaway of a past event
that still haunts her she runs away and
goes to the basement in the middle of
the room is a big box that also reminds
her of something from the past related
to the older shiziko following the
encounter shizuko goes to the
principal's office and asks to be off
the meds now that she is feeling a lot
better the principal agrees and asks her
to return to her room during the next
embroidery class the principal announces
that she is going to choose a potential
candidate who she thinks will win the
competition everyone believes it will be
either casaway or yuka but to their
surprise she chooses shizuko once the
teachers are no longer around yuka
attacks shizuka for taking away her
opportunity after being banged on the
cupboard several times shizuko screams
and pushes her back the force causes the
cupboard glass to shatter into pieces in
a fit of rage shiziko grabs yuka by her
neck and lifts her into the air her
strength surprises everyone and no one
dares to stop her she only comes back to
her senses when yuka falls unconscious
then casaway asks her if she is fine
even though the pieces of glass have dug
into her palm she claims to not feel
anything casually is left speechless
because her old friend shizuko also had
the same experience she starts to shake
shishiko violently asking her to reveal
her true identity in the following scene
casaway is lying unconscious on a bed
with shizuko by her side taking the
opportunity shizuko opens casaway's
diary and sees her name written all over
it there is also a box drawn in one of
the pages that she recognizes as the box
in the storeroom when chisico goes to
check casaway regains consciousness and
follows her a flashback shows us that
the older shizuka and causeway were in
the storeroom one day shiziko had a
seizure as kahira did earlier her hands
were wounded but she couldn't feel
anything and she kept on asking cause
away for help but casaway pushed her
aside because she was scared when she
returned with the counselor a while
later shiziko had disappeared without a
trace they were told that she was sent
back home but the night still haunts
causaway back in the present she and
shishiko go to the principal's room and
snoop around hoping to find out why
girls disappear from the sanatorium
suddenly the principal and a japanese
soldier enter the room before the girls
can be seen they hide behind a cupboard
they overhear the principal talking
about an experimental use of a drug
after the two leave the girls open up a
safe with a key inside they find files
about experimental drugs that are being
used on the girls it turns out that the
military is trying to create a drug that
will breed soldiers with superhuman
strength they are funding the sanatorium
so the principal can use the drug on the
girls to test them out till now they
have found that the drug provides
temporary superhuman powers before
causing death this explains why casaway
could jump so high and why the girls get
seizures and disappear the next day in
reality they do not disappear but die
because of the drugs being fed to them
daily the girls are interrupted when
they hear the others yelling on stepping
outside they see yuka on a tree branch
she falls off of it and dies the girls
are asked to go back to their room by
the counselor then she notices that
shiziko and casaway are not with the
rest of them outside they are running
through the woods to get as far away
from the sanatorium as possible they
ultimately reach a military base and
have to stop as they are about to turn
around and run in the other direction a
soldier catches them when the girls
retaliate casaway gets shot in the back
shizuko whispers something in her ear
and runs away while the soldier brings
casaway back to the sanatorium then the
principal sedates her and restrains her
to a bed meanwhile shiziko arrives in
her office and retrieves a gun to help
casaway she finds her in a room and
something else catches her attention
before she can help her friend
suddenly the soldier attacks her from
behind and knocks her out in the
following scene we see that the
principal and the counselor have sedated
all of the girls and are making them
inhale a test drug the principal is
ecstatic because her experiment is about
to be successful by the morning however
the soldier has another plan the
principal has been treating him like a
servant and insulting him since the
experiment will be successful by the
morning this means the military doesn't
need her anymore so he is welcome to do
anything he pleases he tells her that he
is taking over the authority of the
experiment but the principal refuses to
cooperate the counselor also sides
against her and slaps her in the face
soon the place is swarmed by soldiers
somewhere else casaway wakes up inside a
box that is being filled with water she
tries to escape but is trapped a while
later shiziko wakes up and runs to look
for cause away but she comes across a
room with several tanks with the girls
frozen inside of them to shizuko's
horror casaway is also inside a box she
cries asking her to come out but her
friend is long dead when the sadness
washes away rage takes over her she goes
outside to kill everyone who was
involved in the experiments that killed
her friend because of her superhuman
strength she easily picks up a heavy
wooden door and throws it at the
soldiers and the principal they
retaliate by showering bullets towards
her but she manages to dodge them and
hide following that she kills all the
soldiers one after another in the other
room the girls have also gained
consciousness induced with superhuman
strength they attack the counselor and
strangle her somewhere else the
principal tries calling the military
base but shiziko finds her before she
can the girl picks her up and throws her
to the ground with little to no effort
then she is making her way to cause away
when suddenly the principal shoots her
the bullet misses shiziko and hits the
box breaking it causaway's lifeless body
falls out of it further enraging shiziko
she picks up the principal and impales
her on the wall in the final scene we
see that the girls have killed each
other growing aggressive because of the
drug that was given to them they have
also embroidered the counselor's body
after killing her the entire sanatorium
is a mess and dead bodies lie everywhere
the only person alive is shiziko who is
sitting by casaway's corpse the moral of
this story is that steroids are no good
subscribe for more videos like this turn
on notifications thank you for watching